a long journey in traffic and we've had
some great to come down from LA yeah
yeah the the the five or the four or
five we'll both treat you badly mmm no
matter what road you're on people in
Gaza don't understand the pain we had in
daily traffic we're good we're good so
we're actually at WonderCon right now
and I love being here people here are so
passionate about movies and TV and you
have you for all of you have you been to
comic-con or WonderCon before just my
first time a tiny thing like this first
time in like WonderCon I've done panels
in my life but I haven't done a panel
with possibly a couple thousand candles
sitting in the audience so it's I'm
actually super excited I'm super excited
about this I was gonna say um there's a
lot of there's a lot of cool stuff
downstairs like something you can buy
and look around is there anything for
you guys you collect or do you even know
what WonderCon like what is seer I
collect the teeth like your baby teeth
or other mothers exclusively got it is
there a place you can buy is it
available on eBay just for their sleep
get in there in the den tonight and he's
a wizard so he what he does is that he
you know it just uses his magical skill
to dig out and when you wake up it's a
nice surprise like I lost a couple
details he actually did my wisdom teeth
which was very considered is how the
TCPS works by the way like you know the
friendship and the fellowship I
understand so this is the way it was on
set all the time it's method I've told
him to be like in their role in the
character normally these gentlemen are
very serious and boring quite boring in
all honesty but they are in character
they're playing you know the characters
at the TCPS a lot of people I'll be
serious a lot of people have seen the
trailer already or the teaser trailer
and trailer talk a little bit about what
for people that actually aren't that
familiar talk a little bit about what
the film is about and as a filmmaker
what was it about this story that said I
want to make this this well I'm
Oh confound myself read the books I
started watering when I was 12 or 13 and
an Hobbit and then Silmarillion and then
more adult age but what struck me is his
emotional own story like he was orphaned
at a very young age around 12 and then
he has to kind of from that dark place
he has to build himself you know he
finds friendship he a fellowship that
guides him through his younger years and
he finds his amazing eternal love Edith
Pratt and that story then you know when
you think about this reading it it's so
touching that it felt like it has to it
has to be a movie talk a little bit
about what each of you talk a little bit
about the character you play what the
film is about what drew you to the
projects okay I play Christopher Wiseman
who is a valued member of the tcbs and
[Music]
Christopher Chris for my money when I
first read it I felt Christopher had a
little bit of a troublemaker inside him
and he wanted to he wanted to test
people he liked pushing the boundaries a
little bit and him and talking
particularly have quite a there's a fair
bit of friction between them on a few
occasions in the in the film and it was
always with love it was always with
total respect never with malice and it
was it was for me playing Christopher it
was always to try and bring out the best
in talking and make him realize that he
was special and that what he did and
what he could produce in the future
would be would be pretty spectacular if
he had the right mindset and and yet the
Christopher had his flaws as well lots
of them as did all the boys really in
their own ways but um but each each
person in the TCPS played their own role
and played a very important component in
creating this unit that they had that
allowed them the freedom to talk about
these you know huge subjects the in
and investigate their curiosity don't
know why that's funny this is really
good very good
just brilliant is this right and I'd
like to follow up on that it was what
was really interesting about when tom
was speaking there but well like the
camaraderie within the lads dorm a
really said a really good president for
us and the first sort of day of shooting
like it it never felt like we were going
on set I thought like we were going to a
playground yeah you know we just felt
like we were always having fun and I was
very being on for another and dorme was
like you know the the invisible member
of the tcbs domain was like we're sort
of you know like like like a sage old
uncle you know just sort of guiding us
into into catering up to shenanigans and
he'd done this amazing thing when we
would have the tick don't leave it go
okay boom we've got it
now this one's for you and III think
that was just made us feel so free you
know and relaxed on sand it was just
really about making just this beautiful
fun film as opposed to you know a very
serious biopic you know that sort of
thing yeah yeah for me and I think
that's the element is so important
because I think it comes through in
Tolkien's writing later on you sort of
see how important that Brotherhood and
that fellowship was to him and yeah
there's not really a way of replicating
it other than just go for it and like
like I said that's what that's what I
don't may definitely instilled in us on
set and yeah it was it was the best fun
I've had on this is to continue in that
this joy of life that you recognize from
the hobbits and in a way the fellowship
the TCPS you know this gang and include
an inkless halt
as talking you know there represent
these kind of hobbits that are inspired
and love life and that was something we
wanted to also to bring the screen so
that the audience could look at you know
the film and I want to be part of that
dujour the free evil of life and
excitement and the inspiration how they
inspired each other one of the things is
I think and there's gonna be obviously
people that know his story and know what
he went through but for the average
person his story is so interesting and
so unusual and so inspiring like there's
so many words to describe his life for
each of you when you when you're getting
ready to do this you're obviously
researching a little bit more die
deeper into the people around him can
you share a little bit about what you
learned that really surprised you I was
I was really lucky to have Robert Gilson
in real life wrote letters sort of
throughout his college days almost daily
to his family and also to to a girl that
he was sort of falling madly in love
with called Estelle so you get you get
this like day by day account throughout
the war of of what he was experiencing
and also because they were so passionate
about writing and and theatre and the
arts that the language that he uses is
so expressive and and you get such an
insight into what although they're
they're experienced in these you know
horrific things on a daily basis he
still notices that the beauty of gunfire
at night and to be able to appreciate
that kind of beauty if it if it wasn't
such a such a terrible thing so that was
I was kind of I had a I had a book of
poetry that was published posthumously
by talking the Jeffrey had written and
it was just that sort of became the
Bible for me you know looking at that
book of poetry and each poem were going
in what situation would he have had to
be in to have written this who is this
about is this about talking about Robert
you know so that was that was a really
sort of interesting thing to have as
well as you having the letters you know
for me it was it was really enlightening
to see how Tolkien's love for fellowship
and acceptance and support in his life
was was then so prevalent in his in his
later works you know how the how the
have a fellowship had such a profound
effect on him that he wrote and created
world around it yeah and and to see
where that came from
it was a really nice thing and for me
it's you know being a fan and having
read the books before you know a lot
long time before I actually researched
or dug into his real life for me the
surprising a lemon was that you kind of
see talking eyes I thought you know we'd
see as Lewis in a pub in English aisle
in Oxford chatting about elves you know
drinking a beer which we did yeah of
course to him but what a surprise me is
this young man who's experienced that
said darkness in a way and found his way
to light and you can also see this
allegory in his life and in this film
hopefully that that you can then read
the books reread the books and get
another layer on them and for me the
books actually are now a more touching
experience because I can read I can see
talking's real-life experiences they're
not necessarily one-to-one but the
emotions that he had that he then
brought in in the books that's what I
think is gonna be so interesting when
people see this movie I think everyone
is gonna re-watch the Lord of the Rings
and see a completely different movie
than what originally they saw you know I
and that's one of the reasons I can't
wait to see this film is just to
appreciate his life even more but I want
to talk a little bit about the editing
room because ultimately that's the final
rewrite talk a little bit about how
maybe the movie changed in the editing
room what you learned about the footage
you had in the editing room
well I mean I've worked with Haru
learner who's edited all my films and we
have this very we have a system or a
method that we experiment we kind of
stretch the material as wide as possible
like here's the script which goes to
from able to B and then the C to D and
then you kind of actually start
experimenting in the you know let's what
if the film starts from this you know
the ending moment what if it is that
which is the fun funniest part and what
possibly the rewrite in the Edit was
that it became a bit more kind of
internal and going more and more into
his imagination and the the the strength
of the story of the fellowship the love
was there and then the third kind of
element how do we portray creation there
was something in the edit we brought
more and more I wanted to bring more
kind of the fantastical images and they
the elements can seeing the more
daughter seeing the middle-earth that I
saw and those characters and I think
that was something that kind of was an
added layer during the post-production
phase that's one of the things in the
trailer you can see a shot of like I
want to say it's gunfire or something
and then you can see the Balrog or you
know that you can see some of that stuff
so that stuff that you did in the
editing room the idea was that this is a
young man sketchy he's kind of a painter
in a way
you know he's doing lines and he's
drawing lines one by one he's creating
and slowly and slowly that you know his
masterpiece is evolving so nothing there
is the ideas nothing there is finished
yet it's kind of a sketch how he first
sees it so the second time he sees it
and then later on he uses that what he
sees or experiences in his mythologies
for the three of you I would imagine
making this movie is an experience
you're never gonna forget but when you
think back on the film being on set and
making this thing what's like the day
that you will always remember that
really stands out whether it be because
someone screwed up or was just an
awesome day on there was a pilgrim scene
and the film and it was just like I've
never really billiard so we were just
crying with laughter I think I've ever
just laughed so much while trying to do
a scene yeah and it acts I actually when
we finished that I went this scene is
gonna be awful I was there's no way this
can look good and whether it was da
Meister acting or parties acting it
looks amazing it's like one of my
favorite pets in the film where parties
character stands up to Owen Teale and
it's it's amazing I think the energy of
all of us know almost breaking and being
firing professionally but it looks good
yeah I know I remember as well good like
a really rapid switch in energy from
like fruit for me anyway when I go to
confront and I think Owen Teale is such
a commanding presence and an incredible
actor that it was impossible to stay in
that schoolboy mode I was like instantly
pulled me over and and that was that was
that was fun but you're great I love
that bet it's really that case it's you
know a kid coming into himself you know
it's like standing up for the first time
to his dad and it's just it's really
cool that I really like that for my
money I I I really enjoyed the rugby
scene when rugby that was our first that
was our first scene that we shot and it
was it was an Oxford versus Cambridge
University probably match in the in the
in the sludge in the mud and we were
playing alongside that so the other
players who were 50 weren't actors were
about 15 16 year old Liverpool
in college students who who play rugby
nearly every day so they know what
they're doing there was no choreography
it was not like it wasn't like okay just
be clear like Tolkien loved rugby and
you know a lot of many of the fellowship
also loved rugby and that that was
actually how originally they're gonna
met on the rugby field of King Albert so
it's actually dramatically important to
his life the specific match what is it
as a director and as actors are you sort
of looking at the first day being like
please let it be something easy or
because that's you know a rugby scenes
like a big kind of thing to do on your
first day yeah and there's some pretty
hefty tackles being thrown at those eyes
grateful I loved it absolutely
annihilated by Anto pretty quickly
there's a great slow-motion scene where
Patrick is running there in the wing and
the Goliath that is myself
just crushes him just straight into the
ground you'll see it's believed it was
really like it's just it's it's amazing
it's just bad form but I usually
director I usually kind of we kind of
need like very we kind of choose very
accurately what's the first team both
actors and in this case I thought that
because its physical it's something very
physical so you don't go into a mental
when they arrive we had already been
shooting a couple weeks when they're all
the TCPS arrived
so it's like okay if we do a scene where
they just chat around or the talk around
what happens it's like we might not
start with the right energy their voyage
so it's actually kind of chosen that we
want to do rugby first the physicality
of it kind of jumping into the film felt
right for these these guys yeah I was
just worried in case one of us got
injured and there's the trip was done
and one was broke a leg in the first day
that's what I was sort of getting I
think when you have is something like
this like like you almost want to save
it for the last day of filming in case
like something goes wrong
do you know what I mean but I think it
don't make completely right there cuz it
just made us just you know called right
here we are let's go head first none of
these things we knew at the time as well
it wasn't like we were aware you know
that you were doing this this stuff kind
of on purpose so and it definitely all
allowed it to I mean you'll begin to it
in that yeah evil master breath there's
always an evil master plan totally um
I'm basically out of time but I want to
ask one or two fun questions for you
what TV show would you love to guess
direct and for the three of you what TV
show would you love to guest star on for
me the answer it's easy I would love to
direct su-metal hoon anyone anyone who's
gonna pay for it was expected yeah I
think there's a there's a first is the
Game of Thrones creators must have read
The Silmarillion a couple of times
there's definitely that there arcs and
the stories of and the humanity and how
we see perceived humans and the evil and
the good size of us and the
philosophical elements of humanity are
in that in that book I would love to do
that
I just and then if I would be able to do
as a young fan of Twin Peaks that would
be my second choice gonna make a new
season of Twin Peaks I would love to do
that I think I'd have to say Fargo I
think just because it's such a wild
style and I'm a massive fan of the film
so yeah there's a French drama on
Netflix called call my agent which is so
beautifully crafted and written and it's
just it's one of things I watched by fun
watching it on my own I find myself
cheering a long ones when something
happens for a character so invested so
I'd like to do that Lord need to learn
French you know speak French okay for me
there was a there was a there was a
children's program on when I was a child
when I was a child and called Balamory
which which I was obsessed with as a kid
and if I could go on and do like a our
guests didn't on that and maybe sit down
and read a bedtime story or like
something like that I'd be pretty cool
it's a PC plum
PC plot know what you got the woman in
the wheelchair she's the teacher yes
yeah our Comment misses
anyway yes I remember yeah I remember
that yeah yeah that would be good enough
my last thing because we're at WonderCon
a lot of people here collect something
whether it be movie posters comic books
shoes whatever it may be is there
anything for each of you that you
collect
I collect shirts and books so I might
gonna wander around and just see if I
find that look about talking or about
analysis of his stories that I don't
have and then I am I love
geek shirts I have a have a shirt which
is basically their you know best brew of
Bree which is the Prancing Pony right
and you know those kind of like shirts
that are you know that those who know
they see this year do you don't it's not
obvious so I love those kind of shirts
that have inner message or he didn't
Easter egg in it I totally know what
you're saying and I agree when it
doesn't say the actual title but it's
something from the movie or something
from the show
I completely agree I don't know I mean
so but because somebody asked me what's
my like geek thing and I I did magic
since I was like nine it's eight now
it's so sexy so many like magic stalls
nomadically gathering they're like even
yes so a bar in New York and party
provoked attack of cards and the most of
been 50 people in this bar party was
bumble it's like David Blaine
he was bamboozling everyone and everyone
was like you know Cheers he didn't pay
for a drink all night it was a pigeon
and squirrel
I thought I'll collect anything I don't
think no acting awards for Anthony just
the words oh oh no I don't I don't
collect I don't like that anal thing no
no it's cool I'm sorry I'd let you down
I've recently started a record
collection so like a vinyls and stuff
sure so I'm on currently I'm on about
it's early days it's only been about
three or four months so I'm on about 15
I'm gonna give you fair warning now it's
gonna get it's going to end up taking
over your flat or wherever you're living
it's an addiction yeah I know a lot of
people where you walk in and it's
you know something out of a I'm looking
at with rent in an extra space said just
to pull so let's just remember gala Toro
has the Bleak House okay here's a spare
house so you know I'm a listen in all
seriousness I really cannot wait to see
the movie and I'm so appreciative you
guys came in at WonderCon I so suggest
walking around the con a little bit
inland walking up and down the aisles
and scoping out what's there you really
it's really like nothing else
I promise thank you very much thank you
so much